now harmful practices against women are
undermining gender equality in
developing countries they're detailed in
the un population fund's flagship report
found almost half of the women in nearly
60 60 countries are denied the right to
decide whether to have sex with their
partners
use contraception or access health care
20 countries or territories have laws
that allow alleged rapists to escape
prosecution
if they marry their victims more than 40
countries have no legislation addressing
the issue
of marital rape and more than 30
countries restrict women's
freedom of movement outside the home
let's speak now to dr natalia kanem
who's the executive director of the
united nations popular fund and joins us
now
from new york natalia welcome to al
jazeera
it's a troubling report it's an annual
report to shine a light on the
emerging issues in the field of sexual
and reproductive health and rights
and this particular edition as we've
said it focuses
on women and their lack of autonomy over
decisions
that should be there so tell us more
about the findings
well yes um since 1978 unfpa
the united nations sexual and
reproductive health agency has
issued reports about the state of world
population
and this year we're making clear that
bodily autonomy
of women has been put at risk by
norms by laws by culture in particular
women and girls are the owners of their
own bodies
yet the denial of these rights which is
a fundamental human rights
leads to nothing less than misery
lack of access to health care lack of
access to contraception
and sadly as you noted nick almost half
the world's women cannot make their own
decisions governing their own bodies
these decisions are made by others
there's startling data within this
report including this one of the 20
countries or territories
have marry your rapist laws
tell us about that
what we see is that sometimes by law and
policy
and sometimes by practice there are
a wide spectrum of practices that are
really harmful
to women and girls let me give you the
example of female genital mutilation
done without the consent of a woman or a
girl
the aspect of so-called
marry your rapist laws this is
a total annihilation of the woman's
right
to be able to find justice when she is
harmed
moreover we see obnoxious practices
for example virginity testing
what is this this is a way of
subjugating the woman's
ability uh because these these tests are
are not real they really don't work but
it's a way of
trying to take power from women the one
that brings a lot of sorrow
to me is the aspect of child
marriage every single day more than 30
000 girls under the age of 18 we've got
to start questioning why
and the report gives the evidence that
shows uh
the consequences of this type of
attitude okay so what about solutions
i understand that the data shows that
higher levels of education
leads to greater decision-making powers
so what what can we do
to to bring better education to people
well you know it actually starts in the
cradle every family
every girl that's listening to your
program right now
needs to understand that she has equal
rights to everyone else
so i think equipping girls and boys to
be able to claim
rights that lead to healthy decisions is
part of the solution
the arguments about whether or not young
people
age appropriate need information about
their bodies
that should be laid to rest they do i
also think
that the report brings up the law and
policy
aspect the violations of these rights
are actually against norms so we're
calling on governments to do their part
we're calling on men
to become allies in this very important
fight
right exactly because it's not just
about educating girls it's also about
changing male attitudes to sex
and women's rights isn't it well i'll
give you a great example that comes out
of niger
niger right now has the highest
fertility rate an
average woman there has uh seven
children
not necessarily because she wants to and
they also have a high death rate
in childbirth because of this high
fertility so what government is doing
there is encouraging men
to attend husband schools where really
they learn about
the human body they learn about how to
protect
their daughter their wife their relative
from the dangers of too frequent
pregnancy and how to access modern
contraception
it's a big success and good luck to them
because men
should step up well it's an important
report we do appreciate
you bring it to our attention and
natalia kenyon thanks very much indeed
thank you so much